austin and i are funeral friends what
does that mean
what have you guys to get rid of the
others porn collection yes
yes clear my history um
no like we're the kind of friends that
um
lifelong it's like i'm going to be at
your funeral you're going to be at mine
i'll bury you you'll bury me
um well both can't be true though right
unless you chime in one of the other is
true one
one or the other yeah yeah that's cool
you've said that before how did you
i feel like you guys have had
conversations about this
this is flat yeah yeah this is a death
pact yeah it's death packed
um have we talked about it before i
don't know i i feel like
there's there's a like i mean look you
can only have six right
that's that's the uh the standard amount
um six death-packed friends
how do how do you weird that's what
friends is about is that what friends is
there six of them
forget they're all dead wait a minute
daniel lindelof was a writer on friends
[Laughter]
amazing uh i feel like uh
there's no way they could have afforded
that apartment in new york that's what
it was
they were wanting it do you think you
look like more of a shitty person if
your funeral is too overpacked
because then everyone's like all
everyone here liked you yeah small
cliffside i don't go to funerals unless
i know the person
no what i love i love the crowded ones
the crowded ones are great like when you
know someone was genuinely
my my my favorite funeral weird thing
like so my my my grandad was like
this like beloved guy in his village he
was he was basically he had two jobs he
was
uh the gravedigger and he rang the bell
in the local church
yes nobody but a brit could tell this
story you're
a tv crew once shot a documentary about
him
because he was such like an institution
in this kind of village life like
it's brilliant because he's just
complaining about like i'll never go to
london because people step on your feet
and he was just he was he was a man from
a completely different era
who somehow was around in the modern day
i love that and he um
but the best part i remember because it
was just his funeral and you know little
village church just
overflowing with people because the
entire village shows up and you know
town's around because this guy is
just known by everyone he's been around
all these families for
decades but something but but the the
thing that annoyed him most in his last
few years
was that his village was getting a surge
of like uh
rich people basically moving to this
nice picturesque village and it annoyed
the hell out of him
so what he used and they used to
complain about about him ringing the
bells because he made too much noise on
a sunday when they were trying to have a
lion
so that church rang its bell for hours
on his funeral it kept they they had a
procession of that every like old
village guy kept that bell ringing for
like eight or nine hours
straight just to piss off the rich
people who moved in that is
wow on which side of the family oh my
mother's
what what's her social security name
it contextualizes
what was your fault just curious what
street did you grow up on
i i want to know all these things
amazing i hate
i want to know my friends like what's
your blood type yeah exactly what's your
mother's name
pretty like upset at myself the other
day when i realized that i don't know
all of my friends favorite pokemon it
just feels like a thing
that i should know about everyone i'm
friends with i think everyone has one
i don't think it matters not me shut up
boston you're already
a guy that's a jigglypuff this might be
a generational thing potentially
it would only apply to my friends who
like pokemon
and hey i have plenty of friends your
exact age mike bithell who like pokemon
okay so so does that mean that you can
have no friends that aren't into pokemon
no if they don't like pokemon okay i
will assign them one like i just did
with austin and jiggly okay yeah be
assigned oh i want one
i want one which one's what's mine mike
what's wrong what is my paul you're an
alakazam
troy okay okay that's the one with the
little
like mustachey beard thing right that's
great
yeah always in my top six you could make
up a name right now and i would believe
you
truman um corfy florf i was going to say
klefki because it sounds fake but it is
real
um charlottesville i feel like
you cleft palate would probably like
i'm forgetting the name is there a
sorting hat that i should be wearing
right now by the way
i'm exceptionally ravenclaw
so i'm glad
like that it's a chickarito that's a
great chicken it is a chickarito
i i once i once dated a chickarito nice
i got drunk in a bar in chicorito like i
uh like something to do with the the way
a chickarito
has it had for all of the pokemon
listeners it has this like thing at the
top of its head that is a leaf
but it's a very stylish leaf and i think
that's right i applaud that
does sound decidedly feminine which is
very fitting for me as well
i'm not a very masculine guy of of the
people pictured here
i'm only second most feminine
[Laughter]
what's what's yours my favorite pokemon
is actually a gyarados um
which i feel is cheating considering
charolanazad
but listen it's just that gyarados has
so much type variety and a really high
special attack
but you can use most uh type based moves
with the gyarados
and it's also very fast you know so it's
just
it's just a real beast it's like a water
dragon that can use thunder and fire and
water
okay somebody somebody who
watches this podcast we just gave you 30
seconds
of solid gold solid gold content for you
to create speech bubbles too
and if you don't do it you don't love
this part you're all fired
go home everyone wait a minute wait a
minute what is this
mike bithell what day have you had today
my friend what's he drinking
look at that oh oh it's friday night we
all ready
i can't even begin to guess what's in
there is that what it is are we are we
going to oh no this is not
this is i'm definitely getting tiki
drinks after this but no for now this is
just a squash this is fun
you guys just went back down into a
pretty serious lockdown huh mike god i
think that's
america you're well lucky i mean i mean
we could definitely do an episode on uh
both of our countries currently well
brisbane just did two and my family
how many people i want to know when the
mayor made that announcement
pulled a james tiberius kirk and
screamed
i like to think i'm gonna make another
matt berry reference and like to think
that they
screamed father like matt barry would
um in the i.t crowd which i troy i just
would like you to familiarize yourself
with matt barrymore so that i can spell
he is incredible i don't know what this
means yeah you should you'll
really like it i'm clueless why are the
nuclear weapons
he's just he's just very good you're not
understanding what we're talking about
you know
he doesn't speak like that it's not his
real voice like he's got like a much
harsher like a cockney-ish
voice did you know he's got like he's
got like records as well you know
yes and that's why coast of london has a
song in every episode
are we still talking about pokemon right
now yeah yeah
yeah i'm still i'm trying to trace this
on to jigglypuff somehow
i feel high right now i feel like cool
yeah it is weird to talk about something
that
you aren't familiar with if i'm being
honest troy like i feel like
where tv and film is concerned i expect
you to know all of it
kind of didn't even watch the pokemon
anime i can't believe it
anyway great time to intro the show i
guess look at it it's eight minutes it
hasn't been 62 minutes yet how dare you
it's a level of professionalism that i'm
not used to eight full minutes
hi everyone i'm alana i'm a video game
writer i'm joined by mike bithell who's
a video game director austin wintery who
is a video game composer and
troy baker who is a video game actor we
all work in the games industry i like to
talk about games industry things every
week
um and i gave you an assignment this
week mike did you
did you do the assignments
well i kind of assigned the last one yes
i will say
wait i think if you're talking about
mandalorian troy that was not my
assignment
going to say austin and i maybe i
advocated for for
getting caught up on mandalorian all
right and i did i am one episode away
oh well then it's a pointless discussion
i figured that it was yeah
there's there's some there's some stuff
that happens in the last episode that
might come up in conversation
that's why i figured but [ __ ] bill
burr man he is
he's great isn't he fantastic holds the
screen
yeah i i had the thought that especially
when watching bill burr in both seasons
and he's also in breaking bad which is
my favorite tv show i've made
that stand-up performance is just a
different kind of acting
and i had not considered that before but
it is still there playing a character
yeah and on stage for a long time
are great actors like generally like as
a rule of thumb
like casting a comedian i mean ricky
that's going to be okay that is a good
performance from a man who is not an
actor
funniest thing he's done ever who i
think i would agree
i just knock it off he's a fantastic
actor yeah like
i mean the last show that he did what
was the last show the uh dying
what is it what was it after life after
life [ __ ]
i haven't watched it yet but everything
i've heard about it sounds like it would
blow me away it is it is uh equally
funny as it is poignant
but that's true of virtually everything
of his yeah
um i think this one is is is remarkably
more poignant
like he's tried to do it before in some
of the movies and stuff but this one was
like
wow you went there um i i mean even the
office
to me was like which was heartbreaking
the office
i thought it was consistently
emotionally
challenging it is extremely
uncomfortable to watch
you know but like heartbreaking yeah
yeah
the the us one softens the blow
yeah i mean it has its moments of real
genuine heart
but the ricky gervais just
conception of the character is one that
you i found myself feeling so bad for
him
even while documentary afterwards the
follow-up
yeah oh my god that's the worst one yeah
oh but i think there's also like for for
the english for brits the tolerance
for awkwardness and is higher
and way higher because we love a loser
and hate a winner that is our national
kind of we i think that's in your anthem
you can't
it is the love it's the one
it's the one non-racist line
um yeah it's uh yeah no it's we we we
we don't like people who are too
successful as a country like
you have to you have to be yeah you have
to kind of
you have to kind of be the charming
loser and but and
most of our comedy is about like people
who are
misguided us to their own like look at
like alan partridge oh my god i was just
about to bring it up yeah like that is
i i don't know if they have they ever
done anything together ricky jovice
island partridge or not ellen partridge
but uh
okay i'm just doing the whole i'm not
sure
they've ever reached behind you they're
politically on very different sides of
the coins
personally so i wouldn't imagine they
get on very well really but
well steve coogan's uh like a very lefty
comic and ricky gervais is
more on your kind of i would have
thought of the coin ricky gervais was
politically
left but i think rich
i think he's politically left but just
doesn't like
uh he's very like anti-sjw yeah the
identitarian
aspect of the left which a lot of
comedians don't like because it's
basically
a lot of comedians are being told you're
not allowed to joke about this you're
not allowed
to make them have to be without exactly
without making fun of trans people for
10 minutes
yeah it's really it's really hard to be
a comedian if you can't trip someone up
um but yeah no fair play but no like um
yeah steve coogan's like a very kind of
freedom of freedom of speech but from
and but well
i guess actually more kind of protection
from the press a lot of the kind of
the murdoch empire stuff steve coogan
was kind of actively
kind of fighting against did he just
stand up as well or is he
i don't who can do it yeah
yeah he did like this and there's some
his stuff has i think like a lot of
comedy over the era has aged very very
badly
uh for a lot of the same reasons but
like yeah he was a lot of characters
alan partridge started i think as a
stand-up character as a character he did
on stage in stand-up
before then getting no sorry no it was
developed for a radio show but then he
did do stand up i'm getting very boring
here about the history of steve coogler
i've done a lot of steve coogan content
on this show
yeah i'm a big fan someone has to do the
new one play watch
have you listened to his new podcast
troy no he did um
audible originally did a um it's uh like
it's an eight-hour
audio book that's in the format of
basically like his failed podcast
attempt and it's just a podcast slowly
going off the road
it's amazing it's it's island partridge
from the oast house
um and it's that sounds amazing right up
my alley
his stuff is the only there's a couple
of new writers who've been working
with uh with kugen on it for like the
last few years and it's gotten so good
oh my god it's a whole cinematic
universe absolutely
i mean this week and i'm sure this is
maybe a good subway for something i
i was actively looking i i don't i don't
like to be the person that's like duck
and i'm out of here i'm leaving i'm
grabbing my family in this country but i
was like
let's let's seriously consider what this
looks like
and i i looked again to
um twickenham was one of the places but
like just
what does it look like to to
is it is it even feasible or am i just
streaming um
and they found that vancouver is like
i thought the prices were wrong i was
like oh maybe they put a comma there
that's supposed to be a decimal point
it's the most expensive place
in the world to live i was like well
that's not going to be where i go
uh but it's definitely been a a very
interesting week
austin i feel is in like the best
position
of all of us on that fateful day
yeah i was i was where you went i was
were you in the riot
i was like you went to the cafe yeah i
was in the freezer
[Laughter]
for legal purposes i'm supposed to be uh
anonymous i feel like
maybe this podcast needs to
adapt to that i um no i was
i was actually in the studio recording
uh
and completely uh unplugged uh because i
was
busy i was working at 11 hour at 11 hour
sprint
um and so i literally got in
to the studio at 8 a.m and
um and started recording and so i i
basically
muted my phone and put it on the on the
conductor podium
so that i could keep track of the time
and then i basically didn't look again
at my phone until
um uh like like 9
30 p.m mine was 5 p.m and it was like
what the [ __ ] is going on
uh i mean it was really quite the quite
the whiplash
i mean it was one of those but the
result was that because the whole thing
had come and gone
it like for all the intense perfect the
actual physical act itself
had completely finished
um it was sort of like the whole thing
had already been reduced to
a tweet length summary so i didn't have
to kind of
go through the real-time analysis of
yeah which made it i was i was
i was overjoyed to be able to
just by dumb luck have you know gone
into work basically
uh to do some recording and uh and miss
the whole thing because yeah i have a
hard time turning away from things like
that
i was thinking that too is like that if
i had
had been doing the work i was doing
while that was also happening how on
earth would i have done the work i was
doing
it's super complicated and obviously
like something that
i keep wanting to say never would have
expected but it was forecasted
they said they were going to do it uh
which i guess i didn't know
and it just just infuriating to watch
the response of these people walking out
of a building that they have
just broken into trespassed and
destroyed as a governmental building i
don't get that you're allowed to walk
away from this
i i would have assumed that if you did
that you were shot in the head i'm not
i'm not necessarily condoning like
actually like that police execution
no of course not but i would have
assumed you storm like them
what i understand to be one of the
political centers of your country
violently aggressively invade that space
i'm i'm shocked that they got out alive
like i i
my presumptions about american policing
[Music]
would be that that would be a bad thing
and you'd get interested i
i don't think you're wrong i think that
that absolutely would have happened
um if if factors had been different i
think that that could absolutely have
been
the case that we would have been looking
at um
not riots but we've been looking at a
massacre
so i it to me it's it's
it's very confusing but i did see uh i
did see that there were
um a bunch of arrests made today
like yeah he's cracking down and people
were like hey man
so by the way the fbi's follow me on
instagram now
so yeah yeah
the guy that broke into nancy pelosi's
office and was taking photos at her desk
was arrested in arkansas i don't know
yeah which is also a federal crime right
to steal something you do it anyway
yeah i mean no i mean i assume that the
capital still storming the capital
probably
trumps it but i mean the funny thing is
also that that i think um
i saw that the the the police like
whoever the
dc police or the fbi or whoever would be
kind of in charge of this
said they had already made a handful of
arrests and they were you know like
just getting started or something was
what they said because i think
so many people turned around and
obviously
fled not like like this guy was arrested
in
arkansas yeah like so it's like a day
later he's already mult many states away
i bet that's true of a lot of those
folks so it's gonna probably trickle in
for a while but i have a suspicion that
because this is one of those things that
it seems like
broadly speaking and i i know there's a
lot to bring to the table about
who who decides to condemn it and when
but it does seem
that there's basically near entire
consensus
across the political spectrum that that
all these people need to be held
accountable
um i mean if even if even trump is at
already making videos to say you know
every one of these people needs to pay
for that it's like
that that's that's a that's that's a
that's an uns
that's a surprising moment but he could
have done more in the run-up right
that's why i i pref i prefaced it by
saying you can
say who could have said what and when
right very still fair point
would you say right i think i think it's
an indicator that there's going to be a
shitload of arrests over the it might
even take weeks i mean some of those
people are probably
thinking they just pulled off something
akin to a spring break
shenanigan and then it's gonna like over
time it's gonna be like
no no this is gonna be like a massive
like
oj trial level event of just like person
after person being prosecuted at high
levels although the one part that i
thought was really
ridiculous was that it said a lot of the
people the
easiest charge to get them with was
violation of the covid related curfew
and i was like i was like that's like
[ __ ] that's like getting [ __ ] half
a time tax evasion like
what a stupid [ __ ] low-hanging fruit
yeah that's so frustrating and it's to
be clear
mass arrest is probably what i would
prefer to happen in any of these
instances
absolutely you know it's not that like
some of the political discourse right
now is
is very strongly if this were black
people who had done that to the capitol
building the outcome would have been
different and i strongly believe that
and when i
say that i'm not saying you should have
shot the white people
it's you should also not shoot the black
people
yeah like in theory everyone should have
been treated
the same way yeah which is to you know
not be
killed uh would be really nice and it is
the thing that's surprising is that
the the the sort of talking point that i
came across as to why
um the response seemed
they found a bone yeah
did you see the gallows i saw that too i
didn't know the story there
i well the talking point that i heard
that i thought was
that i thought was interesting and hard
to wrap my head around was
from the folks that were not sort of
apologists for what happened but we're
trying to explain why the police
response was
seemingly so demure
was because they said that that um
they were just so severely outnumbered
that they couldn't
they that there's no reasonable way to
even mount
a a proper defense against that and i
thought if that is true
so be it but how on earth did it how on
earth were they so outnumbered like
when you have a different walmart
because if it was a walmart yeah i mean
that's the thing
when you have a demonstration of the
demonstration of that scale
yeah there tends to be just basic
dramatically then things are different i
can understand that there's already some
kind of i don't see how they were
outnumbered i don't either because they
had
already like literally down the street
the the amount of personnel it takes to
cordon off an area where the president
is going to be is
insane so you would think there would be
like a
standing army almost practically around
the capital around around
the yeah especially while congress is in
session it's over one of these
incredibly contentious subjects
that's the thing like like
contextualizing it going
yo maybe we should kind of beef up
security this is going to be really
really weird here
that makes a whole lot of sense the
thing that i don't understand
is or or kind of pushed back in the
notions like they were just outnumbered
is when on video you see
dc police moving the barricade and
waving people through yeah that was
that i saw that talking point in the
context of explaining that video because
they said the police
the police protocol i have no idea if
this is true i was just like i came
across this on twitter and was like
you know i don't know maybe it was that
the apparently police have protocol like
that when
when that when their safety is basically
like
if we if we if we have no reasonable way
to stop this
then the safest thing for us to do is to
get out of its way because
we basically are are committing a you
know a death sentence i can understand
this
behind them behind
them was their entire government though
you'd think it was pretty important to
protect
yeah it doesn't make sense to me it
doesn't make sense no i still appreciate
you
i always i'm always i i the thing i
can't abide ever is seeing three seconds
of footage and going
i understand everything that happened
here and and i
and [ __ ] these and it's like whoa whoa
whoa whoa
there's also a moment a genuine moment
of fear they spent like 10 years
studying 9 11. like right there's a lot
that
happens that that is worth especially
when emotions are
just wildly off the rails for sure for
justifiable reasons so
there's i'm all about race deliberate
analysis there's a great
human moment when one of the people that
the
i guess the the point of ingress where
the where the breach first happened
where they were holding up
and and there's a look of recognition in
the dc
police officer's eyes when he realizes
that that badge that uniform and that
gun
doesn't mean anything and it's the same
moment
like in a bug's life when all of a
sudden
the grasshoppers realize that they are
ten to one outnumbered
and it's the fear of like now we're just
two people
and there's more of you than there are
of me and
it's no longer a boxing ring it's a
street fight and there's there's no
decorum there's no protocol
and there's two humans that are facing
off against each other and one of them
is willing to do something that the
other person is not so there's a
definite moment of humanity where it's
like well as a cop you should have done
this is like
at that moment all i saw was a father a
son a brother
a man and that man was terrified
so i don't i don't necessarily say this
is it's it's not his fault
there is a systemic issue that there
should have been more than
two people in a flimsy guard when they
see there's a
hundred thousand people are having tens
of thousands of people
that are starting to get antsy that
should have been
called and yeah and tim and this and
knowing full well what's going on
in the session in that moment wondering
when you guys have like a when you have
a state of the union when you have like
your entirety of
of the congress is in place they must
they must up the security normally under
those
i would think it's hard to come within a
mile of the damn building i would think
you can't i've been in this situation
before where it's like no this is closed
off
like if there's ever going to be you
can't even go through hollywood on the
night of the oscars like
yeah the [ __ ] the [ __ ] state of
the union you would think is just like
the closest
i could get is here in burbank am i ryan
saying that basically this was
everyone who would be at that minus the
president basically right or um
i thought it was just the house wasn't
it i don't think is it the house i don't
know it was a lot of people though right
it was a lot of
house and the senate it's a joint member
of congress joint session of congress
exasperated and the vice president i
hate speculating about stuff like this
yeah the joint piece of staff weren't
there you know there's not like that i
don't know the secretary of defense the
secretary of the state and secretary of
the treasury
and and all those people weren't in
there but it's a hell of a lot of the
the line of
succession of your government if
something bad were to happen in one
place
with what looks like on video as you say
like
some massively kind of scared
normal living level couple i've seen
pictures of like your your
political buildings with like what looks
like an army outside with like
riot gear and all of this kind of big
hefty
none of that was there and that's weird
i don't know
that's what they the photo was like of
them on the stairs when blm was going
down and it's like it's the same thing
as like
buckingham palace right you go right up
to those guards
now those guards are pretty much there
people have successfully broken into
buckingham palace quite a few times yeah
that's bucking your bells now that's
also not you know
10 downing street or whatever that's
that's not um what's the address
10 dining street isn't it next door to
nine downing street
you know what you joke i'm not sure if
there is i don't know if there are
houses on the other side of the street
all right just get yourself out of that
one then there aren't yeah i know where
the old mi5 building is that's pretty
cool
um it's a hotel that's the only reason
why i do that
and all the rooms all the rooms if you
like lean against the bookcase it like
slides over and it's just a nightmare of
missing guests
is that where you've been all this time
but it is crazy like
key and peel thing if you haven't left
the hotel in 50 years
i mean we have guy fawkes night for the
last time someone put a bomb in our
house of like the weather where our
government actually sits
like guy fawkes none of you know what
guy yeah of course how dare you sir
how dare you sir the australian
yeah yeah yeah it's uh it's been a wild
week
hope everyone is out there there was a
kind of vendetta
outfit at the riot and like the amount
of political confusion that that
demonstrates like in terms of like
what do you think people are really
funny
i think a lot of people are just like oh
cool mosque
yeah i was just told that the evite says
dress festive it was either this
amazon cool mask
it's like let's not put that guy in
charge of the manifesto
he's probably not yeah lana you sound
like you were going to steer us away
from this crazy
considerably you know it's it's a it's a
rough week for a lot of people watching
this is
is mortifying for a lot of people so
want to be considerate of that while
also you know openly speculating about
it because of course it is at the front
of our minds and three of us live in the
country
in which it happened um generally
just hope everyone's okay i hope it's
all everyone's doing okay and i hope
that they
get those mass arrests very curious what
happens
yeah i'm sure we'll keep an eye on it um
i would love for news to be boring again
remember that everyone was like ah
boring news i did realize recently that
i don't hear trump's voice anymore
and that was a nice feeling when you
close your eyes at night no just like i
don't necessarily see his name on
twitter every day
he's certainly not on facebook or
instagram right now apparently those
those 12 years
or those 12 years those 12 hours driving
20 20
12 hours as a slave uh without being
able to get onto twitter were
great i was like this is awesome
apparently he was very upset um anyway
i did uh give mike bithell the homework
of watching
the medium gameplay wait wait before we
before we
walk away from mandalorian because
because
uh i do struggle so hard well no
just something it's a comment that i'm
happy to just deposit
and then shut up on that episode with
bill burr the heist one they did
something that they've never done
in star wars before which was actually
very cool which is you know the
the the spoilers uh the the thing that
makes him
snap and shoot the officer who is sort
of
uh talking up the this this battle
that battle was written for and invented
for
battlefront 2. and it's the first time
any of the filmed star wars
shows slash movies have essentially
you know like blessed through canon
something from a video game
mike's about to reach for his bookshelf
that's not true oh
you're close what contradicts that i
don't i don't i i can't think of
anything probably
it's mandalorian it's this season of
mandalorian and i might be getting the
episode wrong
but it's you know the the dark troopers
the big robot
those are from from dark horses horses
yeah they are you're right
so that was the first time so you're
right but you're like wait
only shop at the end do they shop no no
they are or they are there earlier
and you and you see them hinted at yeah
you're right yeah the tps reports made
me giggle i was like that's good yeah
that was funny
i i thought um i thought also they i
they're um the
the other thing that they did that was
very subtle which i
was i even saw it immediately on like
kotaku or somebody was or or one one of
the
you know screen rant one of these kind
of pop culture
sites was like wow uh
cheers to mandalorian for tackling the
most controversial thing in all of star
wars
is an a kind of sidelined remember i
even like
paused it and turned on hill and goes
did you catch that line
where they uh they go into the the base
to blow it up
and they're like this isn't a base this
is a lab
and it's that first hint of maybe why
they're
trying to capture the the baby yoda
and there's like a little bit of audio
bioshock style audio of the
lab director guy who says you know we
need a specimen with a sufficient
m count and i was like wow
they're they're they're just like maybe
baby we'll hit
hit us with it all like this is star
wars true and true and we'll own
all prior star wars and i was like
because the whole thing of like
felony and favreau being like let me
show you how to do it right i was like
that
i just found myself with a lot of little
moments like that where i thought
they're fully embracing all that's on
the table
and i think that's what the whole of the
quote was like kind of fixes
the prequels like that's what that show
does that's what they did with that show
at least legitimate in some ways it
legitimizes a little bit it kind of
becomes the glue and they backfill
so much through clone wars right yeah
the the thing that
that was was funny to me about this
season of mandalorians
it became like a fortnight situation was
like all right let's go and bring out
the next person
it was like tim and elephant and we're
going to bring out amy sedaris
we're going to bring out you know all of
these different people the thing that i
thought
was super cool was bringing out what's
his name
sorry for a camera's name from the
prequels who was jango fett
um to play boba fett and one of the
funniest lines i thought was really
great he was like let's just say that
they'll they would recognize my face i
was like all right that's cool that's
really cool that you guys are gonna do
that
and it's the same thing with um it might
it might be in the last episode but it's
not a huge spoiler i can't remember when
when um when starbuck uh what's her name
yeah well no she's two before yeah she
makes the comment where
she says um you know i've heard your
voice many times or something like that
to him
um uh another clone wars reference
what's her
cara dune is that her name no um
dang it don't bring me into your hold on
her name is uh she
i like i liked her a lot i feel like i
have like spoken awesome about this i
think
a lot of the performances in that show
are
way off you know in a way that like
consistently bothered me
like there's some performances where i'm
like even amy sedaris
i'm like you're really really good what
are you doing yeah i
love amy sedaris and david sedaris david
siddars writing is just i'm a huge fan
but i was no but she's really capable uh
and and
yeah strangers but candy it's like what
are you doing
but maybe the difference between miss
caroline
in princess caroline in bojack horse
princess caroline but
she's also not on camera um fair yeah
special expressions that are the problem
i don't know
uh i don't know what's happening with a
lot of those performances and there's so
many plot holes
and it's just so great i was just like
okay just go in and watch it like even
the fact that
you you have to go these are these are
stormtroopers right but it's
not the stormtroopers from the first one
where they're all clones these are no
stormtroopers where people are enlisted
and they grow up and they you know
that whole thing pause stormtroopers of
the empire
are mostly you
by the time of episodes four five and
six those are not clones those are
overwhelmingly conscripted
okay uh taken in against their will much
like
uh finn uh in uh right right right right
right right
my my favorite scene so far
of the entire show i think i i gotta i
got up i gotta earn
my money it's cool man it's cool it's
important that we stick to the facts
when talking about important subjects
exactly i feel the same about star wars
as i do political analysis
the two we have to wait several years as
the mandalorian dust settles to fully
be able to you know dispassionately it's
wrong to speculate at this stage
exactly the two the imperial troopers
and i can't remember what their
designation
is the guy from from jedi or return of
the jedi
they're on the speeder bikes those two
guys
the the choice for them to just sit and
and stay on them they're waiting for
them to open the gate or whatever
and they're just having to sit are you
being in season one the the no in season
two
they're like they've got the child
and this is like let me see it and it's
just a conversation between these two
guys
season one that's the last episode of
season one oh [ __ ] okay
directed and it was like a revolution so
good because they're pulling out their
blasters and trying to shoot the can
that's 10 feet away isn't that a couple
of like quite well known american
comedy actors as well isn't it like
jason bateman or something no
could could be something i'm never
thinking it's one of them it's like it's
a couple of like
america i can't remember who it was i
need to look up it was
i was howling laughing it was so funny
that was the last episode or the second
to last of season one and i agree that
was one of that was one of the
highlights
of the of the show i would i would clip
that out and just show it to anybody and
go this is why you should watch this
show
but it's such a western it's such a such
an homage to sergio leone it's
it's which not good performances
like episodic 90s tv as well yeah it's
touched by an angel
it's quantumly
who i don't know who that is um was one
of the bikers but then jason sudeikis
was the other one
that makes sense that's who it was jason
sedakis had to be if you're watching a
guy on the right
because he just he was the leader yeah
my only issue with that bit was that i
felt like it was like
they took the essence of taika which you
know naturally he did and then put it
into a scene and i feel like it's so
different from everything else in the
entire show
it just feels like this is the taiko ytd
scene here you
go take this and i was like i will the
rodriguez episode had a certain amount
of like oh this is rodriguez doing the
rodriguez must be fun for them to make
the making of stuff is really
interesting for that show too like all
the behind the scenes stuff is really
really fascinating i highly recommend
watching it obviously the way they shot
it
we've spoken about a bunch of times
being
mostly just one giant screen
in la i think it's in culver no i think
it's marinade already
i'd believe you that's clear close by
which is fine basically the same area
and you know who um
you know who directed the season finale
um
is this season yeah the one that troy
has not watched don't what don't tell me
you don't want to know the direction you
don't know who the director is that it's
honestly
honestly no because it it it will uh
i will watch it through a certain lens
if i find it i'll tell you what
i've liked bryce dallas howard's stuff
like the
no i didn't in season one yeah season
one was the one with the like
atst yeah it was i can spell oh the
magnificent
seven episodes yeah total magnificent
samurai seven
it was it was that whole thing i was
like i don't i don't understand her as a
director
well i think she's better they speak
about that a little bit in the making of
two and that i think that's probably the
weakest episode of that season
um and they were pretty clear about
thinking that
she kind of got the raw end of the stick
and then it was
one of the hardest episodes to direct
and i won't speak on that behalf if you
want to go watch that totally check it
out but they do dive into that in a
really interesting way
um because i really didn't like that
episode i was like that's where i was
like oh no
like very much fell off of it but then i
feel like in in season two
it's a different ball game i guess
that's the
water one right the fish fish people one
yeah exactly
i think which i like the second series
which is great yeah i think that overall
that was cool on that planet that was a
fun planet
yeah that was fun and it's it's still
super cool to see the x-wings like
every time they pull in something from
like
original og whatever it it definitely
makes me go like that
once that one thing was like uh go ahead
still gonna need that ping
like that note right there was super
cool and also when you go you just see
them go
and like the x-wing come out i was like
yay it's a very fantasy show like it's
very but it's lagging about it
but it still also hits on two like a
casual fan like me i get a little bit
annoyed when like i can tell that an
emotional impact is based
on you recognizing a character from
clone wars interesting because every now
and again because you can it's almost
like when you watch
like an old hollywood musical or a car
or old hollywood comedy where they're
paused for the laugh and it's like
theater like you're
they're waiting they know you're gonna
they they're expecting you to to react
to it so there's a lot of times where
i'm watching and like a character will
appear
and the music will swell and be like
that's interesting austin what were you
gonna do like yeah sorry i i was
i mean i don't entirely um
disagree but i do think that
the the fan service
at least with respect to comparing it to
the sequel trilogy
is how to do it correctly because
it makes it makes a lot of deep cut
that's like
there it's not for the casual uh
observer
and it also um uh is
like not it's of secondary importance
generally speaking it's not i don't
think it hinges
like you could watch the show having
never watched any star wars ever and i
feel like
just as invested in the dynamic between
oh it's definitely like
who those characters are yeah like i get
it like there's also i mean
rosario dawson is beautiful
in any situation just anything
she's always she's always a badass she's
always gorgeous and she's always good
yeah she's getting her own show uh as
ahsoka too which is which is pretty cool
sure that's like 50 star wars shows now
there are quite a few of them coming
there's like the third
extra x-wing pilot's got a show we're
gonna do it all
yeah the one thing i also will add i
know i promised a single comment and
here we are 10 minutes later but uh
the um the other thing that i will that
i will add that i
that i'm very appreciative of um which
probably comes as no surprise but i
think ludwig's
music on the show is broadly speaking
the
the best contribution to star wars
since musically since the prequel
trilogy i think he
he outperforms even john williams music
on the sequel films which i found
generally not that interesting
i think i agree with that i don't like
most of it other than rachel yeah like i
like
i like rey's theme kind of on its own
even though
i think it stacks up poorly against the
giant catalog of brilliant themes that
he's done it just happened it just was
the best part
that's the thing the prequel scores
everybody that's one of the few things
everybody agrees on about the prequels
and um but i thought there would have
ludwig and his collaborators in the form
of
david dave filoni and john favreau and
the various directors and whatnot
they do a good job at avoiding musical
fan service as well and and in fact it
was noticeable that the only time i ever
saw there's two that i can think of
quotes of existing star wars material
uh one i will not mention because it's
in the final episode uh and that whole
final ep
you know ludwig won an emmy wows
at the fox scoring stage recording the
last episode
that he won the emmy for season one
while they were literally
tracking episode uh eight of season two
and i
i wouldn't be surprised if that score
wins him a second and fully deserved
that score in all the dark troopers
business uh reconciling right
reconciling i need to go get another cup
of coffee do you want to get this off
here and i'll go get a couple no no no
you do you do you but i promise no
spoilers all i was gonna say is that the
the invocation of yoda's theme
um in the ahsoka episode was the one and
it was a very
it was a drive-by thing but it was
unmistakable and i was like it's the
only time i've heard
him quote anything from the existing um
do you think that's awesome so out of
creative choice or
i mean i know that there's been getting
that
music has been really challenging
do you think there's any reason why they
they
would have preferred to have done pull
in these
familiar themes but couldn't because of
some legality or do you think it is
purely creative they don't know 100
yeah they own it all hundred people not
shy about using elsewhere right
yeah if i were directing a mandalorian
episode i'd be like jewel the faith's
jewel of
yeah that's the thing and i think it's
to their credit that they resist that
because that's exactly the thing that
the sequel trilogy suffers from like
like
like quoting verbatim the when when
ghost luke pulls the x-wing out of the
water
the whole long sequence verbatim of that
exact cue when he
when yoda does that on dagobah and
empire strikes back like
it's the laziest thing and i watched an
interview with john williams it was very
clear this was not his idea he very
tactfully was like
yeah so the suggestion was we could
maybe reprise the piece and i was like
yeah i could
see him rolling his eyes in the back of
his mind also i've never heard someone
say
quoting verbatim in terms of like
reusing music is that
uh commonly star wars oh that i don't
know
but star wars is definitely full of that
in practice that george lucas
uh constantly yanked his music around
and like episode
episode two is full of music from
episode one and uh there's a lot of
point of a theme though is to be
you know i mean like literally john
williams wrote something they were like
thank you very much shove it aside
grabbed this other thing he wrote and
just stuck it in instead they're like
playing the soundtrack album onto the
film as well
kind of yeah yeah return of the jedi
source music as opposed to
no because music means it's coming from
within the world and that the characters
can actually hear it as part of the
diagesis but it's
but but they're just licensing it as
like
as if it was score music that that he
had written but
he wrote it for a different saying for a
different film i've misunderstood that
term i've always heard like a source cue
is um we're going to put in david
bowie's let's dance
um but that's only happening you're
saying that's only
ha true source means there's an actual
on-camera or
implied on-camera source
like a radio like if you're in a
doctor's office and you hear
girl from ipanema coming through a guard
you know like a scratchy
overhead pa system the camera doesn't
have to show you that but no one
watching that would
fail to understand why there's music in
the scene and so the lights
have done that is the imperial march in
solo oh god the worst
what a heinous crime that was i learned
some stuff today
mandalorian how does that happen then
that's my biggest question with
mandalorian because it is such an iconic
and original soundtrack
in a in a universe which like you say
has been kind of like
yellow lining heavily on the graves
doesn't happen is that f
is that favre it's fabulous i i i can
tell you from personal experience and i
hope i'm more or less
just a genius like i assume that's
probably true he absolutely is
uh but um but you know because if for
those who aren't aware you know
the fact that tenet came out never mind
so i haven't even seen the film but the
fact that you know
he he tossed that score he's seen that
film i don't know
well it's more of an experience he uh
the fact that um
you know christopher nolan has been
working with hans zimmer for like 15
years and when hans basically said i'm
not available
to do this film because of um dune his
commitment to work with
denny villeneuve on dune and his just
single-minded obsession with making sure
to get that score right
nolan went to ludwig which was
to me that was some of the biggest news
in the composer world because you know
nolan could literally there's no one who
will not take his call he could
no composer i mean i remember a few
years ago uh
i mean this was probably 20 years ago
denzel washington was was uh
directing for the first time and every
compose like james horner and people
like that were calling and saying i'll
do it for free
what is it direct for the life of me i
can't remember what movie it was
oh and some oh god deja vu
i'm fairly certain that he ended up
hiring michael janna
but um it was really bad troy
oh it's so bad i never actually saw a
deja vu
you don't need to you know oh it's fun
come on now
i think i had a fun time i tried to
watch wonder woman
and turned it off i don't want to
opening seems great that's like richard
donner
yeah kind of vibe yeah it was um it was
antoine antoine fisher said about it
2002. that's right
there you go 19 years ago um but in to
your question
ludwig is a genius yes he really is and
for those who don't even know
the extent of it when he's not uh
writing fabulous scores like mandalorian
like
creed black panther for which he won an
oscar
um he and childish gambino are writing
songs together
uh like this is america and redbone
for which they have won two grammys and
and four additional nominations tony
then he just needs the time
he's only missing the tony he he at age
at age 36 he's he's 36
he and i are younger than that we're
five days apart in age funny enough
he's five days older than me you were
50. i thought you were older than the
whole time it's all in the look
but um no so yeah he he is a fab he also
he also co-wrote a lot of the songs in
the trolls movie with justin timberlake
uh that came out
at the beginning of lockdown uh he he's
a he's a genuine beast
he he's a he's a fabulously talented guy
and and um what i started to say in
terms of your actual question of how
does it happen
it was mike you asked you can't tell
that i'm gesturing at alana on my screen
i should have just i should have just
kept my mouth shut um
he um the answer is so ludwig's wife is
a is a good friend and she's the
violinist
that i work with um on a lot of things
named serena and she um
i remember we were recording something
here at the studio a couple years ago
and the news had just come out like that
day or
earlier that week or something that
ludwig had been hired to score the
mandalorian which was still
shooting it was like it was basically
known that there was a thing coming
but but nobody knew what it was yet or
whatever but they did announce that
ludwig was writing the music and i and i
said hey
can tell him tell him congrats that's
that's a fabulous thing i can't wait to
hear what she
what he does what he does with it and
she said she said basically
favreau uh pull brought him into the
office and said
your stuff is super weird and that's
what we want
uh like he basically specifically said
we are
not looking for a john williams wannabe
we're looking for an artist who actually
will bring
and imprint something on this that makes
it its own thing
and boy did they get it uh you know how
cool though
how smart a move to do because every
instinct with star wars must just be
pulling you towards just play the hits
just play the hits oh
as a star wars fan that's the thing i
would want to do i'd be like but can my
scene have that
i thought yeah to me the only successful
the ironically the weakest film far and
away is solo
and yet it had at least prior to
mandalorian one of
the greatest scores because john powell
wrote that score
and it was really clear from listening
to it that he was deliberately trying to
absorb a lot of john williams isms but
there's also so much that defines
john powell he has such a strong voice
that it really almost felt like
john powell and john williams had a baby
and it and it's called solo
and but they they do lapse into fan
service like
using the um the
escaping the death star you know
fighting the tie fighters from
from episode four using that cue elana
verbatim
uh in the middle of solo was just like a
blatant fan servicing moment that had
nothing to do with the movie and was so
just bafflingly weak uh
and it didn't seem like it was john
powell's idea so yeah it's like even in
a situation where you have this amazing
world-class composer who is doing all
kinds of awesome things like the
bulgarian women's choir for those those
like bounty hunter whoever who end up
being like the seed of the rebellion or
whatever the [ __ ] was going on with that
like a lot of really interesting musical
choices that he's that he's doing but he
was still so constrained by this
obsessive
you must make it fanservicey
um and yeah it's a shame so this one
this one sidestepped that
just magnificently a director who knew
how to
step out of the way and had the courage
to do so you know and i loved i loved
this little meme that got thrown around
of
like a photo of jj abrams saying it is
impossible to please
fans of the original films and like
younger new audiences or something like
that and then just favro below saying
hold my beer and it was like
yeah how much money has he made for
disney like between that and marvel like
it's unreal we over the over the break
i i said to angel you know a movie
you've never seen and with all this
[ __ ] fabro in our head we just have
to watch as rudy
and wow so he's so charming in that
movie he's so good as just this
unbelievably awkward guy
and uh and i was like can you imagine
watching this and just thinking like
that guy is gonna be one of the single
most like driving forces of our
culture uh a couple of decades later i
mean to just kind of like
birth the mcu hand that off and be like
okay what's next let's let's hey let's
do the jungle book because i got this
idea for the lion king all right what's
next star wars let's do star wars next
and it's like
have you ever seen made
no it is
it it's after swingers and it's when
it's he invents fontini back up again
but if you want to be like oh i forgot
that guy was an actor
and he's so good swingers holy [ __ ] that
that
phone voicemail scene is like one of the
great monologues
ever yes you you need to watch maid uh
and also chef like directly
he directed me chef's great chef is
great but mate
made is all about it's for for someone
especially has a british sensibility as
far as the awkward and just like
this guy it just
if you've ever had a friend you're like
i'm i want to apologize for my friend
like if you think that's bad in swingers
watch made it is so bad and sam rockwell
uh is in it at in just a hilarious
capacity
um it is it is so funny
it is so funny and so good um
i've definitely never seen i've heard
horror stories about john favreau as a
director
um but i also just believe that he's
incredibly particular
and i have heard he's very intense yeah
he's yelled at kids
yeah maybe those kids should get their
[ __ ] together
he considered uh he considered uh
a little history i shouldn't say who who
it is because this was told to me in
confidence but there's a composer
that he was considering for iron man
before they ended up with ramin jawadi
where he uh met with the composer this
is a very
very well-known composer and and favreau
goes
uh i really think uh we should have like
electric guitar and orchestra you know
because it's gonna be like
it's iron man you know we want to invoke
like you know black sabbath and
ac dc and and metallica and like so the
score should be doing the same thing and
and um composer goes you know the
problem with
or like heavy metal and orchestra is
that it ends up sounding like
wwe and it doesn't it doesn't really
like
feel what you think it feels like and so
you know he's like i would strongly
encourage we would not
do that or something kind of diplomatic
of like i don't know if you're going to
like that as much as you think or
whatever in the meeting
at which point favreau is like okay cool
thanks for coming in and then calls
the agent and goes that client is one of
the most arrogant [ __ ] i have ever
done i don't ever want to talk to them
again
blah blah blah and uh amazing
was very upset and uh did not hire this
person
well um i have to go
i never got to ask her
if we could just keep it real simple
this is now a mandalorian
question i'll do it in two sentences for
you later what's your question the
medium the way that it um
by the way try great work it splits uh
you know you're effectively is it two
game worlds in real time and how is that
different to the way that split screen
co-op functions
it's very similar to the way split
screen corp functions it's actually
technically not super difficult which
only shows how
brilliant a creative choice is um it's
it's it's
there are technical challenges to it and
there's some places you can see in that
gameplay demo
some stumbling in terms of video
playback with the
one of the cut scenes it's playing video
in the bottom half but live gameplay in
the top with some frame rate starters
there are some interesting things going
on there
and they've taken the idea and run with
it but the reality is that the
most decent kind of game developers
could prototype something similar
very quickly which is a testament to why
the hell has people not done that
how brilliantly creative a solution to
the problem
i'm really excited about exactly it's
basically yeah from a technical
standpoint you've nailed it it's
basically
like doing cop split screen the
different all you all you have to do is
drive two characters simultaneously what
they probably are doing
i would assume is actually those worlds
are absolutely the same world just being
with different assets being rendered on
the two different cameras
which again we talked about how first
person shooters do that with
your gun and yeah your gun isn't
actually it's all of the same stuff
um so yeah i would love to talk to you
about how
demanding split screen called could be
because it never even occurred to me
before watching that medium footage and
being like
is this the same split screen co-op how
how does that how difficult is that
versus just playing everyone really
wants to jump to xbox live
like cop is yeah it's it's technically
can be very challenging
but you know doable like it's been
doable since then 64.
that's true uh austin what's happened to
you
i'm i'm i'm i'm i've been shamed for
ruining
[Laughter]
one quick comment about the mandalorian
and now i have to title the episode
something to do with mandalorian god
damn it don't you don't you dare it's
like mike bithell answers
episode you said was like people who
gave us so much [ __ ] cyberpunk
that has one of the most views we've
ever had yeah i knew it was
so controversial but it's also
was the thing that i think it's it's not
at all clickbait because my point was
that i kept bringing up
cyberpunk i kept trying to talk about it
and we kept getting off track
it's exactly what the show is that's
what
is and someone's going to drop it is
like he answers it in 58 minutes
because it's really you do totally do we
but that's the the fact that the split
screen when when she's talking to the
girl in the cutscene
you've got video playing in the bottom
half and what looks to be
gameplay footage that's kind of
stuttering a little bit because it's not
been optimized it's not a release game
yet
that's a really interesting insight into
the kind of decisions that may be made
for a
gameplay demo or trailer that i would be
surprised if that goes in the same way
in game i imagine it was a decision made
quickly because what you would do is
either you'd render the whole screen as
a video my assumption and again probably
completely wrong
is that cut scene in game isn't actually
shown from those two views
but because they want to showcase that
feature they pulled an effect i mean
troy do you think elsewhere
if i know the answer to which sorry uh
does that cut scene with the girl
uh where she's talking to she's talking
to the little girl do you does that
actually i think that rep
i don't think that presents as a split
screen in the actual game i think that's
a choice they've made
no i'm not saying they're being
dishonest i think they're just
showcasing a feature from elsewhere in
the game in the bit they're showing
there
they i mean that is that is the same cut
scene
that they just shot two cameras for
because you're not live action at that
point but is it presented
one of them is being rendered in real
time i think and one of them is being
rendered video just from the frame rate
i
again i guess i don't know yeah but
you're not on the stick
no you're not on the stick but it's
being rendered one is pre-rendered
right exactly and then what is actually
happening in engine essentially that's
interesting yeah and that but that's and
that's
not traditionally that's not how you
would do it
in the actual pipeline because you
you're the reason there's some video
stuff
again all presumption would be because
it's tough to run a video and game but
it's harder to run video and gameplay
simultaneously than split screen
gameplay
for all right but i it feels like one of
those choices that was made for a cool
demo but actually in game it would be
either all pre-rendered
or all real-time yeah there was
something in that demo that that
kind of stuck out to me that was like
game play not final and it was like
they've been working on this game for a
while just just a a a brief synopsis on
this and
a lot i don't need you to go um
yeah get the hell out of here please
make please make troy the hostages
this was uh one of
the first time that i ever went to dice
not as a hey i'm gonna go hang for the
party and drinks and the awards show was
this year
and it was one of the last times that i
was on a plane and the last meeting that
i had before getting on that plane
boston and i had coffee and then um and
then he
he left and i said uh i've got one more
meeting that i gotta go to
and it was with the bluebird team and
uh as i recall you said i have to go
meet some polish people i've got some
polish people
and we met in the lobby of of the aria
and we sat down and they showed me as
like we want to work with you on this
game here's the character
and uh we sat there for about an hour
and a half having coffee and i was like
uh they showed me also who's who's the
composer the music is i think they've
announced that have they
uh i'm i'm almost certain it's two
people uh
yeah yeah there's an internal team and
there's something that they did
uh brought in just in case they haven't
hit that beat i don't wanna almost yeah
i don't know if
that's public either um but i will say
this that i heard
like a bar and i went i know that is and
um it's really really cool so that was
another thing that drew me to that as
well honestly was the composer
um what it was also the team's um uh
their their pedigree and the legacy of
titles that they've done before is like
you guys do a lot with the very little
it's a huge team it's like right for for
their size there's like 120 people i
think of the team
um so this was this is the composers are
public
huh the composers are public they that
would be cool so it was akira yamaoka
and i heard like a bar it's worth it's
worth not sweeping under the rug uh our
friend uh
uh who um also scored uh like
blair witch and and layers of fear one
and two which i love
i actually just got an email from ark
this morning he was sharing this the
score with me
good dude really really yeah i had the
pleasure of conducting his music in
concert in poland
really uh uh uh-hum i'll i'll send you
this link i'm sure he would love to
have it uh he'd sent me the score i did
that
in there oh no way i was supposed to go
to poland and do the full performance
capture and everything else and they
ended up
there's a lot of members that because of
covet they're like we have to shoot this
and so they
shot it very very quickly um and
unfortunately i wasn't able to be
i wanted to be on set um and they were
gonna put me on stilts
kind of cool stuff uh so that team was
able to any any team that was able to
put a game out this year
or last year uh is is truly a phenomenal
feat
uh so i i can't they didn't delay a
month didn't they yeah but that's all
losers yeah obviously a lot of people
did
uh incredibly stylistic cool cool choice
i
agree i'm really excited about it i i
really like everything that they do
um for sure it's very very interesting
super stylish should we do an episode on
gameplay demos and why
developers do the things we have to do
in those demos at some point because
that is a really because it's so often
framed as like developers lying
and actually there's lots of very good
reasons for sure we should definitely do
an episode on that i would love that
because i feel it's a really interesting
cross-section to show i was like there's
so much stuff that you don't know about
um
that they kind of dropped such a weird
point the point where you're doing those
kind of
marketing materials is such a weird
moment in most game devs
cycle so it's a really tough interest
yeah especially when you have to
showcase features that aren't
finished and you don't know if you're
going to be able to share that point in
the game
super interesting um the one more thing
i was going to say about uh sorry just
on mandalorian is no no no no no no no
no no
no no
just just like
if if you took
[Music]
and you put him in an 80s
car howie mandel in a delorean is that
all right anyways see ya everyone um
was that worth costing alana her job
i looked at i was mandalorians what if
you spelled it m-a-n-d-e-l-o-r
is that a man wrong all the time i
always spell mando because it's because
they call it a man
at this point you're right even i have
all right
yeah see everyone